their moves are severe and violence  offenses and already showed signs of a  terrorism  pancha government of China who never  allowed a few violent offenders to drag  Hong Kong down a dangerous road  dangers abyss we've never allowed anyone  to harm the rule of law and some  development in Hong Kong who never  allowed anyone to undermine one country  two systems at any excuse  should the situation near Hong Kong  deteriorated further into unrest and  controllable for the government of the  Hong Kong Special Administrative Region  the central government would not sit on  its hands and watch we have enough  solutions and in our power within the  limits of basic law to quell any unrest  swiftly